antonio costa se queda en el palacio de
belem y con mayoría absoluta contra todo
pronóstico el partido socialista repite
por tercera vez en la presidencia con
más del 40 por ciento de los votos una
mayoría absoluta no ve un poder una
mayoría absoluta no significa poder
absoluto no significa gobernar solo es
una responsabilidad añadida y significa
gobernar con iu para los portugueses
y para todos y todo eso y es si este
mayoría será como me diría así que esta
es una mayoría de diálogo con todos los
partidos políticos del parlamento y con
todos los portugueses en rueda pública
en realidad ganó tras una legislatura
llena de bloqueos de la oposición que
terminó en elecciones anticipadas por no
poder aprobar en los presupuestos las
encuestas no lo vaticinaban pero la alta
participación electoral y su gestión de
la pandemia han disparado el apoyo al
político de centroizquierda
muchos portugueses sintieron que debían
honrarlo y mostrar respeto por el
trabajo que antonio acosta hizo durante
la pandemia y creo que es una de las
razones que llevaron al partido
socialista a tener mayoría absoluta
a pesar de ser uno de los últimos países
de europa en caer en las dinámicas
ultraderechistas portugal no ha sido la
excepción con el partido llega como la
tercera fuerza política del país algo
que preocupa a muchos
no esperaba la victoria del partido
socialista pero esos son los resultados
que tenemos
el ascenso de la ultraderecha es una
vergüenza eso me preocupa
ahora con un parlamento más hostil por
el ascenso de la derecha pero más
estable por su holgada mayoría el
gobierno de costa será el encargado de
gestionar el paquete de 16 mil 600
millones de euros de la unión europea
para la recuperación por la pandemia